dans cette école de montigny maternelle
et primaire s'associent pour créer de
drôles d'engins comme 160 classes du
département il participe au défi
technologique organisé par l'éducation
nationale
objectif construire un objet roulant les
sticks sonne comme une chaîne s'appelle
à engrenages circuits électriques
systèmes de transmission pour les
enseignants des quatre classes de
l'école qui ont participé c'est
l'occasion de développer la culture
scientifique des élèves mais aussi leurs
aptitudes à travailler ensemble à la
fois les compétences citoyennes arrivé à
coopérer à écouter l'autre à se mettre
d'accord
et puis au niveau scientifique comprend
que pour qu'un objet rouler faire un axe
de rotation utiliser les bons matériaux
oui quelque chose qu'ils avancent dans
leur réalisation justement rencontrant
des erreurs et c'est à partir des
erreurs qu'on va avancer dans la
démarche scientifique et la démarche
d'investigation
chaque classe a eu trois jours pour
concevoir ses propres mini bolides
l'objectif c'est déjà un petit peu de
travailler la technologie en classe
puisque on les fait manipuler découvrir
des matériaux découvrir des outils et
puis réfléchir à la façon dont on peut
construire par étapes
un objet donc ça demande beaucoup de
tâtonnements décès et le but c'est
effectivement d'arriver quand même la
construction de l'objet qui répondent au
cahier des charges
tous les objets réalisés seront exposées
à la maison de l'environnement à magny
les hameaux à partir du 4 juin